germany's chancellor angela merkel is
preparing to visit regions of germany
affected by severe flooding that has
killed at least 156 people
merkel is due to visit one of two
regions hit by the floods
the disaster area in germany spans more
than a hundred kilometers
near the borders with the netherlands
and belgium where the district of
arvada was the worst hit a massive
cleanup operation is underway
as rescue crews search for survivors
more than a thousand people are still
missing dw reporter kate brady has this
report from some of the flooded villages
around
bonn
destruction and debris on every corner
the only sound on the streets mud being
scraped away
and tractors rumbling through the once
picturesque town
of arvila here in avila the
water has subsided and it's only now
that the real true
extent of the damage caused by the
floods is really coming to light a lot
of people are returning
to their homes for the first time since
the floods the scenes are devastating
for those returning
the owners of this home moved in only
six months ago the flood water
reached halfway up the walls of the
first floor
we couldn't react quickly enough to move
our belongings
we had to sit upstairs for 24 hours
because the fire service came and asked
have you been hurt if not then you'll
have to manage on your own
but at least we're alive
i'm living there are so many dead
this is it's unbelievable you can't
imagine what's happened here
volunteers family and friends have
traveled far and wide to arvala to help
those affected
they're here clearing homes or supplying
people with the basics
this morning i was handing out breakfast
down by the river there was a family
that couldn't come out of their house
so i got the supplies to them over the
balcony via the garage roof
um
many locals right now want financial
help from the state
quickly and with as little red tape as
possible
further north in efstadt a donation bank
at a school has been
overwhelmed with clothes and food
the donations have stopped now because
they just kept coming it just became too
much
there's definitely plenty of willingness
to help
some locals evacuated from afstad this
week are also being sheltered at the
school
many feel left in the dark
there should be an official from the
city that you can talk to here even if
they don't have much new to say
but at least then you'd have the feeling
that they care let's go
for dimension come to commences we don't
know whether we'll get in our house
again at all
can you even live there or is it all
gone forever
for many of those affected that question
could take weeks
months if not years to be answered
and dw reporter julia saudelli is on the
ground for us in
schuld a town of 660 inhabitants uh
julia how's the situation there
just a few days after the flooding
yeah where we're standing now we're in
the upper part of schulte of the town
and behind me one can see the
devastation
and all the destruction that the water
has brought through the town some of the
houses that were closer to the river
have been
completely swept away houses further
back further away from the water are
destroyed up to the second floor
some are completely gutted filled with
mud and debris it's really a dramatic
situation and it's not only the
destruction of things
the death toll is has been growing still
the police in the area have said that
only in the availa area here where we
are now
they have counted up to 110 deaths and
they expect the death toll to
continue increasing and they are
currently searching the area
with helicopters to try and recover any
victims
julia german chancellor merkel is
expected to visit the area
where you are today i'm going to come
back to you in a moment but we have some
reaction from people dealing with this
disaster there first
i think it's very important that our
political leaders show up here
on one hand to express personal sympathy
but also to get a picture of the
situation on the ground themselves
and then if necessary to promise help
financial help or government help
via the bundeswehr or via the technical
relief agency
if they bring shovels buckets and brooms
and lend a hand
i think it's fine that they come i'm
already here but if they are just coming
here to gawk
i don't think that's okay then they
should please stay away
and angela merkel the german chancellor
as we said
earlier is going to be visiting that
town where you are now
you've been talking to people what kind
of reception is she going to get
some people are quite skeptical of her
visit they think it is just a photo
opportunity
during the election campaign and are not
really convinced about her visit
while others think it's a good idea it's
an important show
of solidarity and support but what
everyone here is telling me is that they
want this
support from the government to continue
even after the next few days and weeks
when the
immediate rescue operations and cleanup
operations are going to happen
people here know that it's going to take
years properly to
to build their towns back up again and
they want the government to be there and
support them
okay julia saudelli in schultz thank you
so much for that
and for more insight on the floods and
how they may affect both medical and
politics and the upcoming federal
election campaign i'm joined now by our
political correspondent emmanuel
thanks for being here um the merkel's
um let's say the party of merkel's
christian democratic union
has as its front runner armin lashett he
could be the next chancellor he was as
we just said in the headlines
seen smiling during a somber speech by
the german president about the floods
explain this controversy yes yesterday
the german president frank walter
steinmeier was presenting his
condolences to the people
affected he was talking about how
heartbreaking the situation
was not only for uh the people affected
but also for
the entire country for uh for germany
and then in the background you had the
frontrunner candidate for the
conservatives amin lachet who also
happens to be the state premier
in northrop westfalia the worst affected
region
uh together with reinan uh about
palatinate he was seen laughing in the
background
so even though he promptly apologized
and said that his attitude was
inappropriate and that he wasn't
laughing at the situation
well this really irritated to say the
least a lot of people
the video got a million view within
hours
yesterday and this could be quite
damaging for his
for his campaign ahead of the election
uh and
would that perception of emotional
disconnect really
significantly hurt the christian
democratic union's chances
the whole party's chances you think well
you know it's not the first controversy
since thursday he already was
seen as being quite susceptible when
journalists
asked him about his environmental track
record in northwind
westphalia and he said no wasn't the
time and a place for political debate
yet he's a politician so when
then can you expect a debate on the
question of climate change which
uh which really is becoming more and
more pressing also
uh you know his track record in
northround westphalia is not
very positive when it comes to
environment for example he allowed
coal mines to run up until 2038
even if he came back on those
declarations uh
in may you know he's now the candidate
for germany
for to become a german chancellor so uh
he
you know he said that this uh phase out
of
coal uh mines of coal energy could
happen uh quicker but he is not known
as being a climate you know you know an
environmental
uh policies maker
and but it looks like the environment is
being
um the global warming i should say is
being attributed as a cause
of the flood or contributing by almost
all of the politicians
in germany and since we're two months
and a few days next to
the next federal election is it possible
that this flooding and the tragedy in
germany will affect the outcome
definitely and how not to think about
what happened almost
two decades ago when gerhard schroeder
who was then chancellor and was running
for a second
mandate uh revealed himself as the
christian councillor the chancellor
of crisis when similar floods happened
uh
uh in dresden more than 30 000 people
had to be evacuated and
on the ground you could see schroder who
until then hadn't really led a very
successful
re-election campaign and who had a very
positive uh track record
during his mandate at chancellor well he
really revealed himself as the
crisis chancellor and that's something
that many were
waiting to see i mean lashed doing and
he hasn't quite
risen to the occasion just yet and that
could really cost him
a lot of votes in september okay two
months to go we'll see how it all plays
out
against the backdrop of this tragedy
thank you emmanuel
while some german towns begin to assess
the damage and clean up others further
south are being hit by new flooding
in the southeast in saxony rail lines
are closed due to rising waters
a state of emergency has been declared
in parts of the state of bavaria
across the border there in austria
flooding and heavy rains are causing
serious damage
in the town of helene close the german
border a flash flood
swept through the streets people living
there had already been warned to be
careful
and to avoid going into their cellars
and basements
other parts of europe has also been
badly affected by the floods
tens of thousands of people have been
evacuated from southern parts of the
netherlands
and belgium is also counting the cost at
least 27 people died there
the region around the moose river was
the worst affected by what authorities
are calling an
unprecedented deluge of water
the floods have receded from the streets
of pepinster
leaving the mud behind residents are
toiling to reclaim their homes
praying that the rain holds off
days of heavy downpours turned this
gentle stream
into a raging torrent houses along the
riverbank
overwhelmed by the force of the water
cars swept off the roads
residents in shock
we've never seen anything like this
before i would never have imagined it
there's been a bit of water before but
nothing like this
we could never have imagined the water
up to the ceiling it's a catastrophe
european commission president ursula von
des line came to take stock of the
damage
and she's promising long-term help
of course the european union has been
helping
with helicopters with boats but i just
reassured the citizens that we will of
course be here also for reconstruction
outside assistance is welcome but the
community is pulling together
to get through the worst
i'm really surprised but very happy to
see the solidarity that has developed
honestly it's amazing
the water is on its way out but it will
be a long time before things get
back to normal